schon wieder verpennt boah ey dafür muss
es doch eine Lösung geben und ich habe
sie gefunden stell dir einfach mal vor
euer Wetter hat die Funktion euch
einfach rauszuschmeißen ich meine wenn
man einfach auf dem Boden aufklatscht
ist man definitiv wach und genauso ein
Bett bauen wir jetzt
dieses Video wird unterstützt von Emma
mehr dazu später zuerst hat Manu aus dem
Team die Matratze am Computer nach
konstruiert so konnte das Bettgestell
ohne Probleme in der richtigen Größe
designen werden damit der Rahmen stabil
genug ist und nicht wieder sofort
zusammenbricht
haben wir uns dazu entschieden richtig
massive fichtenholzbalken zu nehmen was
sie jetzt aussieht wie ein ganz normales
Bett ist ein 2er Scharniere ganz schnell
kippbar damit der Schlafende einfach
runterfällt und sanft geweckt wird vom
Boden der Tatsachen also ab zum Baumarkt
[Musik]
das komplette Holz ist da mega nice das
Baumärkte sowas einfach zuschneiden
deswegen sollte das jetzt eigentlich
ultra schnell gehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so erstmal ein langes und hier ein
kurzes das wird einmal grob fest
gespannt dann reingebohrt
und dann kommen die absolut massiven
Schrauben auch schon rein
[Musik]
die sind echt riesig so und das Ding ist
schon mal massiv
wir haben auf der allerletzten Seite das
ist jetzt ein bisschen tricky dass du
festzuhalten
so aber wenn erste Schraube mal drin ist
gar keinen Stress
das ging jetzt für meine Verhältnisse
ungewohnt schnell beschweren will ich
mich nicht so jetzt komme ich die Beine
[Musik]
das ist ja schon fast im Bett ich drehe
es mal um
also ist auf jeden Fall stabil genug da
hatte ich ein bisschen Angst deswegen
sind die Dinger auch so extrem dick
geworden
einmal hier rein
jetzt kippelt das Bett leider mega
nervig ich schneide das einmal hier ein
Stück ab und hoffe dass es das problem
fixed
gut noch mal Hand anlegen
jo das ist schon viel viel besser
[Musik]
so rein fertig ist das Bett könnte man
jetzt machen so einfach machen wir es
uns aber nicht muss ja noch diese
rauswerfunktion haben und dafür mache
ich das jetzt einmal noch mal diesen
Rahmen hier der eh schon da ist noch mal
[Musik]
das ist jetzt unser Doppeldecker
das soll man dann klappen können fehlt
noch ein Lattenrost den lese ich dann
hier einfach später drüber und zwar auch
diese leistliche Referent anbringen wird
ich habe jetzt drei verschiedene
Scharniere aber man muss sich das so
vorstellen das einzige was später finden
wird dass man nicht nur selber vom Bett
fliegt sondern auch noch das Bett auf
einen drauf liegt ist diese Scharnier
drum will ich halt einfach das dickste
also vom haptischen vom Bett her ist es
das einfach idealerweise kann ich das
jetzt hochheben
und idealerweise bricht das jetzt nicht
ab das ist echt cool das ist wie eine
Falltür eine riesige geil stell dir mal
vor es ist irgendwie 6 Uhr morgens du
musst dringend raus du liegst ja so
drauf und dann plötzlich so Peng hier
ist dann runter geworfen frech von dem
Bett aber auch geil weil man einfach nie
wieder verschlafen kann finde ich gut
dann kommt noch der gute Lattenrost und
ein kleiner Szenenwechsel weil eine
Werkstatt echt kein guter Ort ist für so
ein Bett
[Musik]
und dann kommt auch schon das Wichtigste
an dem Bett ins Spiel
die Matratze und genau wie bei meiner
normalen Bett dass ich mal selbst gebaut
habe kommt hier auch wieder eine ma 25
hybrid-matratze rein weil auch wenn man
kein Bett hat dass ein automatisch
rauswirft schläft man auf Emma Matratzen
extrem gut und wenn man gut geschlafen
hat ist man morgens fit und schafft auch
von alleine aus dem Bett ich schlafe
jetzt schon seit einem halben Jahr auf
einer Matratze und eine gute Matratze
macht ein gigantischen Unterschied in
der Schlafqualität mit der aktuellen
blackwicks Aktion sind alle Produkte von
Emma bis zum 28.11 und bis zu 33%
reduziert bei Emma gibt es aber nicht
nur super bequeme Matratzen sondern auch
Kissen Decken und vieles mehr zum Thema
Schlaf mit dem Code tomories lieb haltet
ihr noch mal 5% Rabatt on top zusätzlich
zu allen Rabattaktionen auf der Webseite
für die nächsten sechs Monate in
Deutschland Österreich und der Schweiz
ganze 100 Nächte könnt ihr risikofrei
auf eure Emma Matratze Probeschlafen und
sie dann einfach wieder kostenlos
abholen lassen falls ihr doch nicht
zufrieden sein solltet und wenn ihr sie
behaltet gibt es ganze zehn Jahre
Garantie auf den Matratzenkern und die
Bezüge hier kann man übrigens einfach
abnehmen und Waschen also klickt auf den
Link in der Videobeschreibung und spart
mit den Code tomory sleep 5% zusätzlich
zu allen Rabatten bei Emma das Bett
lässt sich also kippen bevor ich aber
wirklich darauf schlafe und teste wie es
sich anfühlt einfach im Schlaf dadurch
geweckt zu werden müssen wir uns
überlegen welche Kraft dafür sorgt dass
das Bett sich plötzlich kippt die
allererste Idee war einfach wirklich da
einfach zwei so richtig große
Sprungfedern rein zu machen und darüber
dann eben die Matratze dann drückt man
das mit aller Gewalt einfach komplett
zusammen macht er hier vielleicht so
einen kleinen Haken dass das alles
einrastet und wenn es Zeit ist
aufzustehen löst sich der Haken und
macht Pam Sprungfedern hauen an voll
raus so wer gefährlich auch mega lustig
aber auch super anstrengend das Teil
jedes Mal dazu zu drücken wenn man ja
morgens auch nicht machen jetzt könnte
man natürlich auch einfach die
Sprungfedern einfach raushauen und da
einmal ein Airbag reinmachen keine
Ahnung aussieht ich habe es einfach nur
geschrieben und der schießt das Teil
dann auch komplett auf hat auf jeden
Fall genug Power aber auch das ist
erstens super gefährlich und zweitens
illegal in Deutschland tatsächlich es
darf nicht einfach jeder Hanswurst an
dem Airbag rumhanteln weil da halt
Sprengstoff drin ist und jetzt die
dritte und echt einfach beste Option ist
dass wir hier einfach einen Linearmotor
reinmachen oder halt vielleicht sogar
zwei davon und die sorgen dann dafür
dass man das ganze Bett einfach
elektrisch hoch und runterfahren kann na
das Gehäuse man hat so einen coolen
Kolben an diesem Kolben hier ist einfach
so ein Zahnrad mäßiges Zeug und das ist
ein ganz normaler Motor drin und in dem
ist auch wieder ein Zahnarzt drin der
Motor dreht das Zahnrad das Zahnrad
schiebt diesen Kolben Rasen rein und
damit können unser Bett hochschieben in
echt sieht so ein Teil so aus wir haben
zwei Stück das eine kann hier 100 Kilo
drücken und ja wenn der Theorie kann ich
das jetzt einfach eine
Autobatterie ran drücken also ich stecke
das jetzt einfach mal rein
und dann fährt er einfach aus es ist
komplett geil
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wieso ich das so lustig
finde was und egal wie Facebook
ich kann es nicht stoppen weil der
einfach echt strong ist so ich habe
jetzt ein bisschen was gebastelt jetzt
geht der Motor einfach auf Knopfdruck
raus okay und jetzt muss es nur noch
verbaut werden das mal kurz hochheben
also er kommt hier hin tatsächlich ist
jetzt ein Ticken zu hoch aber man kann
es auch noch ein bisschen schräg machen
dann ist das auf jeden Fall gar kein
Problem jetzt muss ich nur kurz testen
wie groß das Teil ist wenn es
ausgefahren ist ist schon eher das passt
also der rollt man auf jeden Fall raus
ja top ich hoffe das immer fest
die sitzt
also es ist jetzt erstmal nur einer drin
ich packe trotzdem noch mal Strom dran
einfach mal um zu schauen ob das in der
Theorie jetzt schon funktioniert
das ist so geil das geht einfach mit
einem Motor schon ich feiere das es ist
so cool
er kippt einfach bevor ich das aber
komplett hoch war bei euch erstmal einen
zweiten Motor rein
[Musik]
Alter ist das geil das ist einmal
majestätisch
[Musik]
das ist aber geil und da rollt man safe
runter wir probieren es gleich mal aus
und dann nach 10 Sekunden
fährt automatisch wieder runter es
komplett geil jetzt hört man halt hier
nicht irgendwie dazwischen sein Finger
haben das wäre ganz gefährlich wir haben
jetzt leider nichts an programmiert dass
das irgendwie automatisch erkennt dass
das hinterlegt
[Musik]
geil okay ich nehme mich mal rein also
wir werden jetzt auch einige Ideen
wieder dafür sorgen können dass das Teil
gesteuert wird also irgendwie hier so
eine Tastatur oder so einfach ein ganz
normale Wecker den man hier einstellt
per Tasten oder so oder halt eine eigene
App fürs Handy ja die erst super
komplizierte programmieren gewesen wäre
und hatte Pascal einfach die geile Idee
man kann einfach sein Handy mit so einem
Bluetooth Verstärker verbinden nachdem
ich mein Handy auf Stumm bis heute auf
den Wecker wenn jetzt der Wecker
klingelt geht ein elektrisches Signal
aus dem Verstärker heraus eigentlich in
den Lautsprecher aber das haben wir
angezapft und dieses leichte Signal sagt
diesen muss man jetzt einfach dass ihr
losfahren sollen drum muss ich mir jetzt
einmal den Wecker stellen jetzt so Angst
so ich lege erstmal runter das probiere
ich später noch mal aus ohne Schutz so
einfach Wecker gemacht auf 10 Sekunden
und das zeige jetzt dann los oh mein
Gott jetzt bin ich gespannt
also hat genug Power es ist auch langsam
oh mein Gott also und ich kipp
ich merke schon wie ich langsam runter
rutschen
also ich spanne halt jetzt gerade an
aber wenn ich local lassen würde wäre
ich schon ich werde nicht runtergefallen
also die Motoren sind jetzt noch ein
bisschen anders eingestellt wir sehen
jetzt auf keine Gefangenen eingestellt
hilfe ich habe so Schiss also mein Arm
geht schon Flöten und der ganze Rest vom
Körper kommt hinterher
[Musik]
ich probiere es jetzt aber mal da oben
zu bleiben und schaue ich es schaffe das
Böse ist wenn du dein Finger da rein
kriegst dann liegt er nicht nur die
Kraft raus meine Motor zieht auch noch
an so lange bis es okay nächste Runde
diesmal versuche ich einfach nicht
runter zu fallen ich meine vielleicht
kriege ich irgendwie schon mit morgens
und will einfach nicht aus dem Bett und
denk mir so nee ich schlafe lieber noch
ein bisschen
[Musik]
Alter das wird so weh tun wenn man da
einfach nicht drauf gefasst ist es tut
jetzt schon weh ist mein vorm absurd ja
ja das ist es ich werde auf jeden Fall
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen also
Helm ist ja glaube ich echt sehr sehr
wichtig aber mit dem Kopf immer voll auf
dem Boden sondern das ja zufällig dass
ich mir das leisten kann
[Musik]
perfekt Wecker wird gestellt auf 15
Minuten ab jetzt ich habe mega Angst
gute Nacht
[Musik]
ich habe es überhaupt nicht kommen
und dankbar dass ich dieses
Schutzkleidung getragen habe und
Adrenalin ist komplett oh mein Gott
ich bin immer noch ein bisschen perplex
gerade ich muss überhaupt nicht wo ich
plötzlich
gespannt bin aber ich bin wach
also es hat funktioniert ich bin
definitiv Bach ein voller Erfolg unseren
zelandung aber ich habe geschlafen wie
ein Baby auf deiner Matratze Link in der
Videobeschreibung und mit meinem Code
tomories lieb gibt's noch mal 5 % Rabatt
zusätzlich zu allen Rabatten die es eh
schon gibt und ich bin damit raus
macht's gut